welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Vasa and Rick and Morty season four just
released a new trailer for its final
five episodes coming May third assuming
this isn't the cruelest April Fool's
joke ever I think we're good by the way
historically Rick and Morty celebrates
april fools by doing nice things like
streaming at season 3 premiere early not
by doing what everyone else does on the
stupid non holiday and the lie look even
if I have to explain these episodes from
quarantine you son of a [ __ ] I'm in use
these episodes are bringing back Tammy
snowball evil Morty I'm gonna break down
this trailer frame by frame for all the
visual clues and animation details for
how these episodes will go down let's
get started okay the opening shot glides
through an army of Rick's now this
location is actually the waste-disposal
portal in the citadel shown in these
season 3 tales from the Citadel episode
it's where the forest and miny Morty's
trekked to throw in something of value
to try to get a wish but this portal
wasn't a wishing portal but a garbage
dump notice on the right flank is a
battalion of nice sakes last seen in the
season 4 premiere used by the akhirah
poor Bogle on crystals Morty to dispose
of the cops and on the left flank is
some other alien race looks a bit like
male gaze or pians this return to the
Citadel almost certainly means a return
of evil Morty current president of the
Citadel perhaps here he's deploying this
army on our Rick and Morty to stop them
from threatening his power keep in mind
that it's possible that our Rick and
Morty doesn't know about evil Morty's
existence or doesn't really care Rick
uses as Rick pewter to initiate an
unnecessarily badass suit up causing he
and Morty to shoot up into Gundam
Voltron style armor suits with swords
the animation includes the animate
crosshair lens flares love it they're
fighting these deformed beings all of
which have these separate face suckers
latched onto their faces now the host
beings have separate green eyes and
stalks pig noses actually this was the
race of beans that we saw in the season
4 intro sequence the shot with a giant
naked Morty rising from the water and
these were these same races the turrets
from the resort with the immortality
field and the world leader Lee
conspiracy episode now these folks that
face huggers over their mouths and
wrapped around their heads it seems like
a take on the alien xenomorph
facehuggers who latched on to the hosts
a similar way but rather than using the
hosts as a dormant incubator in which to
implant a chest burster these face
huggers control their hosts motor
functions Rick and Morty are slaying as
they always do these things an attempt
to locate and rescue
summer who has comfortably stolen as a
ruler now in a different part of this
episode Rick tries to get Morty to use
one of these dead facehuggers as a
disguise after it was already on his
face though it's not probably dead okay
now it's dead next we see Rick drinking
a potion that allows them to grow some
extra arms if they suckers cover Rick's
ship and then Rick straddles a giant
direwolf in the snow-covered world
behind them are statues of armored
wolves standing upright or if we
remember earlier this season Kalon
hoarders special victims Morty pokes
some fun at Game of Thrones by depicting
dragons as these indulgent horny sex
beings maybe now we're seeing another
example of sexualized Game of Thrones
animals or maybe this is a new canine
world that snowball mentioned heading
off to establish we will go to a new
world and colonize it with a society of
intelligent dogs one that will not make
the same mistakes as humanity and one
where pet insurance will be mandatory
then there's a real crazy shot of Morty
floating in a trance state as like
ghostly projections of his mutilated
body or sucking back into him now it's
glazed over eyes look like his Tetsuo
self in a season premiere maybe we're
seeing Morty's various bloody fates from
the shards of the foreboding long
crystals collapsing in on themselves and
one reality to be honest I don't really
know what that sentence means Rick tells
Morty that if anything goes wrong which
it won't jump into the same vat of acid
I jump in okay wait wait what in which
we see Morty and Rick doing this later
in the trailer maybe it's a nod to the
Joker's classic origin of falling into a
vat of a chemicals and his
partner-in-crime Harley Quinn doing the
same with Rick and Morty having a
similar toxic partnership and we see how
Rick's ship has a drop down rotating
Gunners seat like the gunner pods of the
Millennium Falcon and of course the
animators remembered to include the Mike
reverse battery in the engine now look
at this surface of the sky above here
it's kind of porous organic looking like
a cave or some kind of crest I wonder if
all of this sticky golden goo covering
the buildings could be the honey of
jerry's own honey bottle that shows a
blader in the trailer maybe we're seeing
Rick and Morty take out some bacterial
or viral infection that has grown inside
Jerry's stupid honey and then there's a
return of Morty's super-smart dog from
season one snowball originally named
snuffles but he changes name to snowball
because his fur is pretty and white but
he still it's Morty call him snuffles
he's in his robotic suit in his fight
with a super smart capped luckily his
laser destroys his cat's cockpit blowing
it to a bloody carcass could this super
smart
be connected to the mysterious talking
cat from earlier this season the one
voice by Matthew Broderick the one other
theories could be a sexual predator
based on Jerry's horrified reaction
matching the horrified reaction to mr.
jellybeans in that episode if so that
cat in every cat like it deserves to
burn in hell
Rick and Morty get swatted Jerry flies
through a tunnel and naked Morty runs
from a few Rick's Morty seems like you
just respawned from that pod suggesting
it could be Rick's clone respawn chamber
and I golden do could be connected to
the other possibly honey location we saw
but then big return here Tammy she's in
a lightsaber duel with summer we last
saw Tammy on her wedding day with
birdperson revealing herself as a
federation agent and be trained everyone
Rick rained hell on the Federation
headquarters and the Citadel and his
escape from federation custody in the
season 3 premiere here Tammy's uniform
has the federation logo suggesting that
the federation survived in some form and
behind them is that statue of snowball
that we saw in his kingdom in season 1
suggesting this battle could be
connected to the battle that snowball
was in maybe the federation has aligned
its up with evil super-smart sexual
predator cats it would be just like them
to do that ultimately I think we can all
agree Tammy just needs to be done in by
the return of Phoenix person rig
aborting get beaten up by this jacked
old dude another image that we saw in
the season 4 opening credits meaning
that this is going to be an actual
episode and then Jerry eating some
pancakes with his Jerry's own honey
defend themselves I have dreams and how
summer now is this real Beth or clone
Beth we're at the end of season 3 it
wasn't really sure which Beth we were
going with from there forward I'm
thinking here this is real Beth coming
back because clone Beth would never be
this non confrontational with Terry and
it kind of sounds like Beth has just
returned from whatever trip she was on
and now she's checking in on everyone
the trailer ends with Morty and Rick and
Gundam armor piling up these hosts or at
all or am i taking too much adderall
yeah that's the trouble with adderall
you never really know where you're at in
the journey which of these episodes
seemed most interesting to you comment
down below and if you're new to this
channel remind her to subscribe because
we go all out whatever Rick and Morty is
in season breaking down all the hidden
animation jokes each episode along with
our after-show Rick's plane where we sit
down with special guests from the show
and who knows we might also try to do
some live watch alongs of each episode
on our discord channel which you can
access by becoming a patreon at
patreon.com slash new rock stars follow
me on
Twitter a te vas Paulo new rock stars
thanks for watching bye
[Music]